can you give us a three-to-one like a
and then we'll get started actually Sean
ever for a one-two-three
no on the count of three on the count of
one how did this how does it how does it
usually what's the idiom Josh how does
it usually get said does anyone ever say
okay on the count of one
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less I'm Joshua fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists you were just talking before
this and we were certain when we started
recording this this podcast which has
gotten way better than we anticipated we
were not going to have enough material
to record 20 full episodes of the
minimalist podcast we were thinking
maybe it could be you know a dozen
episodes or something like that but the
questions keep coming in and this one is
about travel today which is perfect
perfect timing Ryan the day that we are
recording this we are getting ready to
hit the road and we're going to be on
the road for about five weeks we're
going to 13 different cities all over
North America and we are packing light
for this now we've we've learned a lot
over the years ever since we became the
minimalist let's we should probably
start before we get into a bunch of
questions and stuff let's let's talk
about our experiences and mishaps a
little bit so our very first tour was
back in 2011 around Thanksgiving we hit
the road and so we had a book come out
called minimalism live a meaningful life
and and with that book we went over the
course of 18 months we went to 51
different cities we did a bunch of
different legs so it wasn't we weren't
on the road for 18 months or anything
like that but around Thanksgiving of
2011 right when that book was coming out
we we hit the road for four cities and
so we started down in Saint Petersburg
Florida and then from there went to I
think was Orlando Atlanta and Knoxville
Tennessee right that's right
and when we got we were already the
minimalist we had simplified our lives
we were we were living the minimalist
dream so proud of ourselves
we were and then we drove down to st.
Petersburg Florida and our tour bus
which is Ryan's Toyota Corolla and we we
get down there and we open the trunk of
the car and it is full of stuff we
packed I mean we each had a suitcase
I had a garment bag for some I don't
know why but I brought my one remaining
suit and put it in a garment bag well
you never know if you're gonna have to
go to a funeral I would never go to your
funeral good you know so we we had this
whole trunk full of stuff so I had a
suitcase I had a like a carry-on bag
even though we were driving I had a
carry-on bag I was carrying it on the
car I guess so the car was pristine it
was clean there was nothing in the car
we opened the trunk and it's just
jam-packed there's a suitcase full of
stuff your suitcase full of stuff my
garment bag we each had a carry-on bag I
think you had a laptop bag and so
there's this trunk full of stuff and it
turns out we are packing all this stuff
just in case and this is where we first
came up with that now famous just in
case rule we call the 20/20 rule right
we realize that we got down we're going
to be in Florida I should pack an extra
pair of swimming trunks just in case
these get dirty yeah it's yeah I get I
need to pack an extra toothbrush like
what if I lose my toothbrush right
there's nothing I could possibly do to
replace that toothbrush and and so we
came up with this 20/20 rule and here's
the cool thing about the 20/20 rule the
just in case true and we decided we're
going to spend the rest of the tour
packing only the items we needed we're
not going to pack any just in case items
and so we spent the next year and a half
we've got on the road for four or five
days at a time maybe a week at a time
sometimes and we while we were on the
road we would pack only the stuff we
needed and if we needed something that
was just in case I'm going to pack this
just in case we knew it could replace it
or at least we thought we could replace
it for less than twenty dollars in less
than twenty minutes now many people are
like oh my god that is such a privileged
stance huh you can't just go around
replacing everything that you need and
spending twenty dollars here twenty
dollars there well guess what you
virtually never have to use the rule
between the two of us in the last six
years we've had to use it five times
that's less than $10 a year for each of
us we're spending $1 a month in order to
be able to let go of all this
superfluous clutter in our lives and so
that rule that started as a road rule
for us then transferred over to our home
as well and so I think I've found that
as we travel more and more I learn a lot
about what I truly need what I enjoy
what I want what what I like to
experience and I'm able to bring that
back to my home life as well as one of
the biggest benefits of travel for me so
we spent that time on the road with our
first book and then in 2014 we we hit
the road this book came out called
everything that remains it's a memoir
that Ryan and I wrote and when we hit
the road we had learned a lot up to that
point after traveling a lot and we hit
the road with just one carry-on bag each
and there's a great video about this
from our documentary minimalism a
documentary about the important things
and part of that it was following us
around on tour and each of us packed a
carry-on bag so so many people Ryan
asked about that bag you know when you
and I we both had the same bag it's from
a company called Malcolm font EA and it
is a now-defunct company so I'm sorry
that so many people wanted that bag it's
phenomenal bag I've had mine for years I
just got a new one recently a new bag
other than that because we've been on so
many tours of beating the hell out of
this bag and finally decided it was it
was time to to after many years upgrade
you had the same bag for a long time and
when Colin Wright was traveling with us
we all three had had the same bag and it
kind of looked like there was a
traveling cult on the road
you knew my bag because like oh the
little leather things on the zippers
were all ripped off of them that's how I
could tell mine apart you're a bit more
rough on on your good I don't know why
that is man I am like so rough on my
stuff it's not even like I intentionally
try to be easy on it but but still
somehow I just like wear stuff out
really easily well you know it's because
you're the big burly man
and what I like to tell myself yes so I
I think that if so many of you have
asked about about that bag and I'm sorry
I don't have a good answer for you I'm
trying a new bag and so if you want to
check it out I think we'll probably be
posting some stuff online on social
media on on the Twitter's and on
Facebook and we'll do some behind the
scenes video on periscope and also on
what's the other one though the kids are
using Instagram yes you know I don't
think we'll be on Yik yak but we're
going to be on the road a lot right and
so I got this new bag by a company
called Menaul I'm not recommending that
necessarily telling you go out and buy a
new travel bag but if you are interested
in and taking a look at what I'm using I
supported their Kickstarter they our
friend leo who is in our documentary he
recommended this this travel bag by by
manole this is their second iteration so
they had a well-funded Kickstarter a
couple guys from New Zealand I believe
and they've created this really
wonderful bag that's going I think it's
35 liters or something like that that is
a great travel bag probably larger than
I need now after we record this podcast
I am going to I'm going to go home and
spend about 10 minutes packing for this
tour we're going to be on the road for
five weeks and it's going to take about
10 minutes to pack on the tour so let's
let's real quick let's talk about what
what we've learned so we were on the
road in 2014 we did those 10 months we
learned a lot about what I need what I
don't need why am i packing this extra
stuff but there is some stuff that
actually might surprise some people in
terms of what we travel with so what are
some of the things that might surprise
people that you travel with Ryan well we
got to travel with good coffee
oh yes that was part of the video like
we we every time we go to a city we make
sure we find really good coffee and but
that's because we were just tired of
crap coffee well yeah that's kind of it
it's like you go to these cities and
some of them are just coffee deserts and
don't get me wrong I'm not above the gas
station coffee but I am find
way some of us aren't if I can find a
way to consistently have awesome coffee
then I then I definitely go out of my
way to do that so yeah we would it was
great because we kind of had this very
very simple setup with a pour-over with
a kettle a very small kettle it made a
you know boiled like 12 to 16 ounces of
water at a time and we'd go to these
coffee shops throughout the United
States Canada and we pick up some really
good beans and we'd be able to kind of
carry those on the road and have a
little memento from that city that was
actually bringing us value you'll be
happy to hear something I got us a hand
grinder for the road this time so the
really yeah you've been so against the
hand grinders yeah I have been except
yeah Joshua Weaver
talked you into it he really did yeah
the person we so we sort of coffee shop
down in st. Petersburg Florida earlier
this year called bandit Coffee Co you
could find them the minimalists com a
slash coffee house you can check out a
little photo tour we did down there but
one of the the cofounders of that coffee
house he really talked me into getting a
hand grinder for on the road and I used
it a couple weeks ago when Beck's and I
went out and stayed in that container
house in the middle of nowhere up in
Montana and we had some great coffee
with us so Sean our fearless producer is
here with us he'll be on the road with
us as well and so in terms of packing
I've already encouraged him to pack very
light this is his first time going out
on a whirlwind tour but when we were on
the road in 2014 we brought the coffee
kit in fact Sean if you don't mind let's
put some some links to exactly what that
looks like so we have a v60 pour over we
have a couple just portable coffee cups
that go with it actually came with the
little kettle that we have and it goes
into this neat little it almost looks
like a table kid or some sort of
toiletry bag we bought it in San Antonio
yeah I was going to say we that's
exactly exactly we're at this coffee
shop and we were like man such good
coffee I wish we could bring this with
us and like low and behold they had this
like little travel kit that you could
buy we didn't buy the whole travel kit
we just bought the pieces that we needed
right oh yeah it certainly has helped
out a ton so we'll bring some really
good coffee with us I just ordered some
dogwood coffee from my favorite roaster
in the United States they're in
Minneapolis Minnesota and so we'll bring
some of that but as Ryan said as we're
on the road what we'll pick up different
you know different coffee along the way
I'm going to pack some t-shirts I'll be
wearing an outfit so I'll have my one
pair of jeans with me my pair of boots
with me I'll have a pair of workout
shorts it also double as swim trunks and
and just regular shorts so I find that
one of the keys for me is packing items
that function as more than one thing now
we're going to be traveling in late
spring so it could potentially be cold
or a little bit chilly in some places so
I'll have my jacket with me I assume
you'll have a jacket with you too but
but what what else are you packing that
may not be a surprise or that might be a
surprise
um I don't know man I mean it's pretty
normal pretty normal stuff to what you
have toilet Rebeck I get I guess a hair
dryer like some people give us crap
reven hair dryers but dude when you got
to be on TV in front of millions of
people sometimes you got it you got to
have some tools to look presentable
yeah I'd say I've packed the hairdryer
even when I was out at the container
house and middle of nowhere I now that
does not surprise me at all yeah you for
me it makes sense and we always say
there's a serve a purpose does it bring
you joy and and yes there's a purpose
for me is I want to be able to dry my
hair relatively quickly and and not have
to worry but see that's key to being a
good minimalist is having
extraordinarily amazing hair even if
you're Leo Bob alte and he has no hair
it looks awesome on him somehow yeah I
don't think he has hair dryer you don't
think so I doubt it
why not
you know okay well we'll talk a little
bit more about everything that we're
packing but I'll tell you this it's
gonna take me about 10 minutes to pack
I'll throw some t-shirts in there some
underwear so I pack for about a week
usually right I don't know if you're
about the same but I'll pack for a week
so I'll throw six or seven t-shirts in
there six or seven pairs of underwear
six or seven pairs of socks I'll have be
wearing my jacket that I have with me I
tend to pack one pair of shorts yeah
I've got seven shirts seven pairs of
underwear seven socks seven pairs of
socks not seven sex but seven pairs of
socks they're mismatched which kind of
helps me out because when you know one
sock wears out I can just throw that one
away yes like that's not cheap I it's
funny is like sometimes I'm not cheap
with but like socks for some reason like
I just look at him like why did they
have to match I could get some plain
white socks I guess it wouldn't matter
if you know one went bad or not but
that's kind of boring but ya know that's
it man I got a week's worth of clothes
um but then I've had several people ask
like well how do you keep up with
laundry well there's a couple ways to do
it so our friend leo he is like an ultra
minimalist and he lives the same way
that he would travel now he has six kids
so he doesn't travel all the time but he
washes his clothes in the sink he's at a
hotel or Airbnb or wherever so he'll
wash he'll have one or two additional
t-shirts with him and like an extra pair
of shorts and he washes it and lets it
dry overnight I don't do that and my
experience with you is you don't do that
either so often we'll stay somewhere
that has a laundry facility often we
won't and that's okay because there's
usually a laundromat somewhere within a
20 minute radius of wherever you are I
don't know what it is man but I love me
some laundry mat time yeah it's what and
now it's not like when we were kids or
when I grow ever had a washer and dryer
in my entire life growing up and we went
to the every weekend we went to
laundromat over Colony Square and we
there was really nothing to do you just
sat there watching laundry and it's a
weird meditative experience but as a
child it's the most boring thing in the
world but now they have TVs and Wi-Fi
it's like a plane land I I it's it's
unbelievable but so so yeah I wash my
clothes and I'm on the road and so you
can do it in a sink you can find a
laundromat and do it you can allocate
you an hour two of your time to do it
but I think it's important to not over
pack to realize that you can wash what
you bring with you and if I'm I'm going
to be gone for only two or three days
I'm going to pack two or three days
worth of clothes I'm not going to pack
seven eight days worth of clothes yeah I
mean within a week I know for a fact
while we're on the road especially in
the United States and Canada within a
week we're going to come across some
type of laundry facility so I don't
really stress about doing laundry and I
know worst case scenario I could go the
Leo route like if I really needed a wash
a shirt I could totally do that in the
sink at a hotel or whatever and let that
dry overnight so certainly planning
planning ahead like that planning a
week's worth of clothes like that has
helped me out so so much because I did
used to bring 910 shirts on the road
trying to go as long as I could without
doing laundry but then that gets mixed
up too it's like well I saw four shirts
left but I'll have any underwear left so
now I have to figure this out but and
I'd say one thing that I tend to
surprise people and we have a whole
montage of footage of this I think of me
ironing my shirts while we were on the
road last time and it's just because I
was wearing a button-up shirt throughout
the entire tour I just alternated
between it was two or three different
denim button-up shirts that you'll be
able to see throughout the documentary
and it's just I'm constantly ironing
because it's an easy way to if you're
sure doesn't smell but it's a little
wrinkly you desire knit out and it looks
really good I've never seen anyone get
so much therapy out of ironing I
actually I enjoy it man it's it's a
meditative experience for me I have a
really nice iron in fact we when we were
on the North American part of the tour I
brought my own iron with me because
we're in our we were in your car the
whole time and I'm like some of the
hotels we stayed at or sometimes that's
the thing too we would say at people's
houses we'd stay on couches we did couch
surfing we slept in the car a couple of
times we've done all of those things we
slept on people's floors and
so there wasn't a consistent way to make
sure I was ready iron this time I'm
packing only t-shirts so this would be a
different experience for me I might need
some little my outfit I well I might be
stealing your outfit yes walk out of the
house all right
naked Josh stole my outfit again nice
the official minimal is uniform it's
funny how we started in like white tee
white button-down shirts and now we've
gone to black t-shirts yes the
transformation has has happened no I
people often ask Ryan about I mean you
heard this on his solo episode as well
it's number one question Ryan gets like
why do you wear a uniform and it's like
well it's easy it's one less decision
but it's not a uniform that he feels
uncomfortable and so he's wearing an
oversized pink sweatshirt with tassels
it's although you know what the Stoics
some of the Stoics talked about this
where the I believe the the the garment
of the day was to wear like a blue robe
or toga or whatever the equivalent laws
and and I don't think it was epictetus
and they have I don't remember which
Stoica was but there was a stoic who
wore intentionally wore a different
bright color like a purple robe just to
just so people would ridicule him and he
realized if this is the worst I have to
deal with then everything else in life
is easy and and so for me no I like to
wear clothes that make me feel
comfortable
I also they have to be functional
especially lately for me I've been doing
a lot of physical therapy I'm doing
three to four hours a day and so I'm
wearing like a pair of loose workout
pants right now and yoga pants yeah oh
you're just kidding well when you say yo
Kai I think technically they would be
called yoga pants when you say yoga
pants I conjure up a different yes no
that's what I was trying to do these
yoga pants think my legs look great
no and so when we're traveling we're
going to have very little on the road I
mean we each have a backpack and our
computer fits in that backpack now full
disclosure Shawn will be with us and so
he'll be carrying some equipment with us
as well now that's sort of the
number-one rule
your minimalist you just find someone
who's less of a minimalistic on all your
stomachs on them nobody had that dislike
the first trip were ever gonna have to
like actually check a bag isn't it
because of the game because of the
camera equipment yeah camera equipment
in microphones I don't know shiny thing
give me we don't see we don't trust Sean
with a microphone so we make him not
yeah because he's much more intelligent
than us it'll make us sound stupid and
so we we just we just make him nod up
and down yeah he's saying we might just
be able to carry it on nevermind I take
that back we still have gone on tour
without ever checking a bag yeah which
is pretty nice and so I try to pack as
lightly as possible but those two
questions come up all the time does this
add value will a serve a purpose will it
bring me joy and and even if so if it
serves a purpose do I truly need it
while I'm traveling because it's such an
attenuated timeframe and often I will
pack things that double up so I
mentioned the shorts that I can swim in
or exercise in or just wear as shorts
but then also I have a Kindle at home an
ear eater but while I'm on the road I
don't necessarily need that because I
can use my iphone there's an app on
there that works really well and I can
use that to read as I want to and that
allows me to not have to pack an
additional item and sort of weigh myself
down so I try to pack as few things as
possible it's not about deprivation but
I realize I can go without for a while
also a toiletry bag we both have
toiletry bags and pack shampoo and
deodorant and toenail clippers and all
the regular stuff here's the thing I
think you'd be surprised and we we
travel with all the regular stuff we
just don't travel with excess stuff
everything that we travel with we
actually use when I used to travel all
the time we travel for work or whatever
I you would pack all of the stuff that I
ended up never using I have four or five
shirts I didn't wear when I went on that
that
a vacation or I would pack the extra
swimsuit or the the big toiletry kit
where I didn't use most well the extra
suit yeah yeah it's like why do I need
two suits when I'm traveling and and the
truth is there are some people who may
but I didn't and so now everything once
I get back I've used every single thing
I brought with me
you know why you packed two suits is
because you wanted to have options which
just made me think that if you're if
you're packing to give yourself options
you've got the wrong wardrobe because
you shouldn't you shouldn't be deciding
oh what's what's gonna look good on me
like everything everything you have
already should look good on you right
right and so when you're traveling
having having fewer choices allows you
to make that decision more swiftly and
then enjoy the experience of actually
traveling having fewer things means
you're not as weighed down by the stuff
and you're able to enjoy the moment a
lot more our first voicemail question
today is from Grace in Maryland I'm
planning to study abroad in a year or
two and would like to take most
everything I own with me but I use just
about everything that I have which is
way more than the two suitcases I'd like
to take with me like on an airplane how
should I proceed in reducing my stuff so
I can make them more stressful
minimizing decisions now instead of at
the last minute right before I leave
grace yes you you've got a you've got
some circumstances changing you are
moving on to a new season in life and
this happens to a lot of people this
isn't this isn't just when maybe we pick
up and move across the world this could
be if we maybe go off to college
or if we have a child or if we get
married or whatever there are definitely
these seasons that we go through in life
and I know when I go through a new
season I've got to re-evaluate what's
important to me what are my priorities
and it sounds like right now yes you've
got a lot of different priorities so
that couch that you're using now yeah
you're going to have to make a decision
with that you're not gonna be able to
bring that couch with you that dining
room table
all that you and your friends eat at
every single Friday night you're going
to have to do something with that dining
room table you can't fit that in the
suitcase so where I would start if I was
you grace is really defining what are
your must-haves what is it that you
absolutely need this this makes me think
of the likes once needs list that Josh
and I wrote about quite a while back
start with start with what is it that
you absolutely need on this trip and
then and then list out your once what is
it that you want to bring with you on
your trip and then decide whether or not
that's going to align with this new
season in your life but as with any
change as with any major change when we
are bringing in another person in our
lives or with a major move whatever it
may be certainly our needs change so
yeah this is a time to reevaluate those
needs as you're going through that list
too I think what you'll find out is you
said grace that well I used everything
that I want to bring with me do you
really I speak from my own experience I
thought I used all the stuff I wanted to
cling on to but I wasn't actually using
it right I wasn't using it as much as I
thought I was or I was going to use it
one day and a hypothetical future but I
wasn't actually using it all the time
and so as Ryan said you're going into a
new season or maybe there's two ways to
think about it our friend Rob Bell talks
about graduating versus divorce now in
this case it sounds like you might just
need a divorce from some of the stuff if
it's not bringing any value to you but
if some of the stuff is bringing value
to you you are moving into a new a new
place in life and that means you're
graduating from that stuff and it's okay
to let go of it because you are
graduating you're moving on to something
else and when you move it doesn't mean
you can't bring the new things back into
your life you can but you can do so very
deliberately in the future but by
letting go of the things that you have
now you'll be able to find them a new
home you'll be able to let those things
add value to someone else's life here
because if something is going to be very
difficult or maybe potentially very
expensive for you to move a lot of that
stuff overseas now I if you find in a
new home I think that's a lot better
than finding it a storage locker over
the course of the next
two three four years I know many people
we've talked to on the road who have had
a storage locker for more than ten years
more than ten years a twenty two billion
dollar industry and your stuff's just
sitting in there not adding value to
your life not adding value to anyone
else's life in fact one could argue that
it's extracting value from your life
because it's it's always there sort of
on the back of your mind you're thinking
about that storage locker so that is not
a good solution what a good solution is
is finding the stuff a new home home
that means selling some of it you can
get some money for it certainly
Craigslist eBay or a bunch of the apps
that a lot of our listeners have
recommended on on past episodes are a
great way to get started or just to let
go of it there's a bunch of really
wonderful nonprofits in most cities who
are more than happy to find your stuff a
new home for you so let them do the job
so you don't have to but as you're
moving on to this to this new time in
your life I want to say congratulations
it may be the right time for you right
now because it's so far an event you're
thinking about it you don't have to make
any immediate decisions right now why
not practice though remember Ryan's
packing party what a great time to have
a packing party right now if that's too
extreme for you why not have it in one
room and and see what is the stuff that
I actually use that will help you
identify what you're using versus what
you think you're going to use yeah I
have a lot of starving artist friends
who move around quite frequently and
what they will do with the things that
they find really really valuable I'll
give you an example um I got a friend
Rebecca who has these really nice
bookshelves she literally went around
her friends she's like hey I got a nice
pair of bookshelves does anyone need
bookshelves
you can borrow these I just need them
back when I you know come back to
Missoula or whatever and she would go
around and find someone who needed that
particular item and they would put it to
good use
I could tell you what I did before I
moved out to Montana I would not
recommend doing this I put like a bed I
put a washer and dryer and I put like a
chair and my my grandma's garage these
very basic things that I thought when I
come back to Ohio because moving out to
Montana for four years now going on four
year
was not the plan I thought I'd be out of
here six months so I just kept the very
basic expensive necessities that that I
wanted to hold on to and when I went
back to Ohio realizing that oh wait I'm
not going to I'm not going to come back
to Ohio anytime soon in the in the
foreseeable future so I sold it all I
got rid of it I had a garage sale I had
some like boxes with you know different
necessities in it I just like sold
lighting open up the boxes because I
knew as soon as I open up the boxes I
was going to want to keep everything in
there so I sold mystery boxes like
literally just labeled on $1 $2 $3 $4
love that idea because he gets other
people excited to what might be in here
when you sealed them up and it says $5
on you had no idea was in it and some of
it was like some of it was great some of
it was like a bread maker or not a bread
maker I'm sorry like a juicer or like a
mixer type thing um somebody got like oh
my I had like some old kitchen stuff
like you know cans of soup a bag of
flour bag of flour like yeah like just
some hat and he was so excited like no
I'm totally gonna use all this so yeah
it definitely gets other people involved
but you know what's interesting about
that ryan is these are things that you
used in Ohio but you were no longer
using them once you moved out to Montana
and when we're talking to grace here
realize that there are some things that
you use now but you may not use them in
your new life yet you've graduated to
this new place you may be using
different things you may graduate beyond
the stuff that you enjoy right now yeah
it was really hard for me to let go of
that washer and dryer like it was the
nice like front-loading washer and dryer
that I bought when I was in the
corporate world I'm like man I got to
hold on to these it's a really nice
washer and dryer I know I'm going to use
these and turns out the places that I
have rented while in Missoula
they have washer and dryers and if they
don't there's like you said earlier
there's our laundry mats everywhere so I
was able to let those go in fact I let
those go super super cheap to someone
who really really needed them I mean I
think there's washer and dryers I mean
brand new were well over you know two or
three grand and I sold them literally
for like a hundred bucks apiece because
there was a person who I felt like wow
they could really
need this or they could really use this
they need this I'm going to give it to
him really cheap and I felt much better
about giving them to someone who was
going to use them than having my grandma
hold on to those in her garage and take
up storage space in her home our next
question is from James in Los Angeles
but I'm going to be making a move pretty
soon to Portland for school and I'd like
to do a know you all kind of move which
means I'm going to have to drastically
downsize even more than I've done so far
what suggestions do you have for that
I don't have much but I have more than
the suitcase and I've got a cat a
terrible terrible cat so anyway any
advice that you have would be greatly
appreciated why we can talk about what
we did when you first move out to
Montana I moved out just like a few
weeks before Ryan did so let's talk
about that whole process of coming out
here so in the summer of 2012 so four
years ago we were driving through
Montana we had never been to Montana we
were driving back to beautiful Dayton
Ohio my favorite city in the world and
we were driving from Vancouver BC which
is just gorgeous but like it was the end
of this tour and we were just ready to
get home and be back in one place right
and so we were driving through Montana
which by the way takes nine or ten hours
to drive through we'd never been to
Montana and and so really okay we'll
just get through the state we actually
went to sleep in Coeur d'Alene Idaho and
we even rented a hotel and it was way
expensive it's almost like $200 for one
night and I remember Ryan you're asking
the the guy at the counter there why is
it so expensive and he's like you're in
Coeur d'Alene like dude it's midnight
we're gonna get up at 6:00 a.m. and
leave I just need somewhere to sleep for
six hours he's like you don't understand
you're in Coeur d'Alene Idaho and Ryan's
like I don't know what that means
and so we paid the money there was
nowhere else to stay and because we were
tempted to just sleep in our car because
but we had done that three times were on
tour exactly well yeah we were driving
through Montana the next day we had to
get some good rest so we'd be ready to
drive and then we wake up the next
morning and
it's the lake there and coeur d'alene
we're right there on the lake and it's
like oh this is why we have to pay you
know the people this is a tourist town
and the Sun the most beautiful scenery
yeah Coeur d'Alene is gorgeous but then
we got to Montana and somehow it was
even more gorgeous as soon as you hit
that you literally exit zero where you
see the the Montana State sign it's like
it somehow got more beautiful as we
crossed into here and we both kind of
looked to each other in fact I remember
the moment we were we that really sealed
the deal for me we stopped and first off
we stopped to Missoula which is a
Missoula which is about 100 miles from
the Idaho border and and we got coffee
we got some fish tacos and it was just
really cool culture here and it was nice
but then as we left Missoula summertime
in Montana there's this little waterfall
that is on the side of the highway along
i-90 it's the first time in my life I've
ever done a triple take ever and there
it would look like a staged Abercrombie
ad there were two muscly college boys
and four girls two of whom were topless
and they were diving from this little
waterfall into this little like hot
spring or pond or something on the side
of the highway and right as I looked
over I did this trip like I couldn't
believe my eyes like what is going on
here this looks like what every
corporate consumerist ad is trying to
recreate it's happening in this place
right and then I saw a bald eagle five
widows a seagull right so see they get
they get the gist of it yeah yeah so I
saw this bald eagle right and I think
the only thing that could have been like
more cliche American Pie would have been
if it was if it literally was like
toting a American flag in its talons and
we just kind of look at each other so
we've got to come back out here for
something and so we we came back out
here to write a book called everything
that remains and Ryan and I moved to
this cabin in the middle of nowhere it's
in between butte and
Lulla on the side of a mountain in
middle of Montana winter so we I got out
here October 3rd and it was snowing the
day I arrived October 3rd and we spent
in a winter here writing writing that
book but when I came out here I let go
of everything before I didn't rent a
storage locker by get rid of my bed I
got rid of my limited furniture that I
did have remaining my kitchen table that
I enjoyed I got rid a little tiny desk
you can actually take a tour of my
apartment back in Dayton Ohio at the
minimalists calm slash apartment and you
can basically see everything I got rid
of now we rented a cabin in the middle
of nowhere it was already furnished but
it was very limited furnishings it was a
couch in front of the fireplace it was
two beds and a table and I think that's
it Ryan yeah I can't think of any other
furniture we had in there and we went to
there's a little town there Phillipsburg
Montana there's a little thrift shop and
we bothered a little broken desk it was
$3.00 that was my writing desk you
helped me reassemble it we bought some
screws for maybe 50 Cent's or something
and reassembled this desk and reinforced
it yeah yeah yeah I mean why it was it
was coming apart yet and so so we for
three dollars had a writing desk and and
then spent the winter writing a book and
we really didn't need much and so when I
came out here it was just what would fit
into my vehicle and that was it but that
that creative limitation that forced me
to let go of things that I knew I didn't
want cuz my other option was that I
didn't want to bring with me my other
option was of course to rent a u-haul
and so that James's problem right now is
I don't want to rent a u-haul well the
question is what can fit in your car and
while we're on tour I've talked to so
many people who have said I remember the
happiest time of my life in this this
comes up all the time
I remember the happiest time of my life
was when I was first going off to
college I was first moving away from
home and everything I owned
fit into my vehicle I was like wow okay
well what's preventing that from
happening now now obviously there are
circumstances that they do prevent that
from happening but we can still live in
only within our circumstance and get it
down to the bare necessities I'll tell
you moving is the best time to reassess
the things you own that's why Ryan did
his packing party he wasn't actually
moving he pretended he was moving
because he knew that by forcing himself
to put everything in the boxes he would
question what was going to bring value
to his life so James you're at the
perfect time for a packing party I would
encourage you to check out our TEDx talk
over at the minimalists comm slash TEDx
it's Ryan's whole story of him boxing
everything up and slowly unpacking only
the items he needed so people are going
to ask well what did you regret the were
there any regrets of the things that you
got rid of her left behind in Ohio when
he moved it out to Montana and I'll tell
you the only regret I have was his
precious moments collect yes
besides my precious moments collection
no seriously the only regret I have or
that I had was not getting rid of
everything that I put into my grandma's
garage that's the only regret I had when
I went back I was like wow you're
supposed to be a minimalist but you held
onto these like four or five things
which I suppose would be like a lot
lighter than what you know most people
just get a big store you didn't put
everything in there sure um but but in
all honesty though I realized that wow
like all this stuff that I thought I
might come back and use I'm definitely
not going to use I wish I would have
just got rid of it all yeah you know I I
find that it's very difficult for us to
let go of our own stuff right and so
maybe like when you did your packing
party Ryan it was much easier for me to
come over there to your house I just you
swooped things into 50 gallon trash bags
right and then quickly you run off to to
the donation warehouse or wherever and
you donate all of Ryan's mugs and extra
glasses and Blackberry chargers and all
this stuff because if I'm letting go of
it I don't have any sort of sentimental
attachment to it no emotional attachment
to it I just want it out of there and
and but if it's my stuff of course it's
like wait I'm going to need this oh wait
just encased it and it's like well wait
a minute maybe someone else can give me
a clean pair of eyes someone else in my
life can help me add some perspective to
what I'm doing so James have a packing
party it's a party only when you
some friends come over and help you out
with the process so make it fun because
decluttering by itself is boring you
could actually enjoy the process now is
a great time to do that our next
question is from Pat in San Antonio well
when it comes to cars my whole life I've
always had an older car and I had that
because you know obvious money reasons
it's cheaper any TC but it's always had
problems and it always causes stress and
that leads to more expenses and it's not
anything that I really want to deal with
and so recently I finally broke down I
got myself a newer car so I have to
worry about all those all those problems
but now it's a newer car and now I got
all these payments and then that's
causing stress and things that I don't
really want to do with and it gets
complications to my life it's not
something that's valuable to me
but regardless or transportation is
something that you need and something
that you can't really get around without
recently I tried to do bicycling I have
a commute to work takes about three
miles I tried it on a bike takes me
about 20 minutes to get there but here
in San Antonio Texas this is not a bike
friendly environment and it is extremely
dangerous and then that causes a whole
lot of stress and doesn't really add
value to my life so I just wanted to get
your guy's opinion on that Pat you went
into debt to buy a car that's probably
the biggest alarm right there man I mean
for me I avoid debt at all cost that is
why you know when I did have this nice
big car payment I traded that in I'm
actually even traded and I sold it on
Craigslist and then with like the couple
grand I had left over I went and got a
car with no with no car payment so you
know if you're if you're asking whether
or not it's ok to go into debt to get a
car the majority of the time I'm going
to say no I understand that sometimes
that has to be a tool that we have in
our lives and sometimes you have to go
into debt to get a tool to get from
point A to point B so you can pay the
bills but it sounds like you had a car
that was working and then went out and
got a new
or that is something I would I would
definitely not recommend for other
people to do if you've got a car that
you don't have a car payment on like run
that thing into the ground because
ultimately if you're going into debt you
really can't afford it yeah if you if
you're borrowing money for a car that
tells me if you need a loan you can't
afford that car I would never encourage
someone to have a car payment a car
payment means you're tied to whatever
whatever that income is and quite often
and remember remember when we were back
in the corporate world we had one of the
stores you managed I remember driving up
to it one day so you have a bunch of
entry-level employees working there Ryan
and and they made good money because
they were in sales and this one of the
top sales people in the company were at
your store and I pulled up there was a
Corvette two Hummers and Alexis all
right next to each other right and it's
like these people don't actually own
these cars they can't afford them they
think they can afford the car payment on
those affording a car payment doesn't
mean you can afford the car you can
afford the car if you can pay cash for
the car if you could pay cash for the
car then then you can afford it if you
go into debt that literally means you're
not able to afford the car you're able
to to get a Delon for the car so
therefore you don't own the car the
title is is not in your name and and so
you said you know there was a lot of
hassle with car repairs but then you
bought this car and there's worry and
stress were the two words are stuck out
that's a lot more hassle to me going
debt and having having that burden held
over my head so Pat what I'd recommend
to you is if you can't pay off that car
I recommend selling it and finding a car
that you can't afford there are many
people who can afford a $500 car a
thousand dollar car two thousand dollar
car and over time you can upgrade to
something that you can't afford that two
thousand dollar car becomes a five
thousand dollar car yeah there's nothing
wrong with owning a nice car as long as
you can afford it yeah and he said he's
three miles away from work our office is
actually it's it's 2.8 miles away from
my home I walk to work all the time I
bike to work I know that you said San
Antonio isn't the friendliest biking
city
I've been in San Antonio it was probably
the friendliest biking city out of all
the cities I visited in Texas now that
doesn't mean that biking that makes
biking safe because I think biking is
inherently dangerous just like driving a
car statistically is inherently
dangerous it's up to you to really
decide on the best way to get to work
but I love walking to work I mean last
week I was averaging like 12 step 12
thousand steps a day and a lot of that
was because I was walking back and forth
from the office which was a three mile
John it's probably what seven eight
miles something like that yeah it's
about sea-ice about six miles and then I
owe 12,000 12,000 steps it's about six
six and a half miles something like that
um but but my point is is that there are
other alternatives I understand you want
to have a comfortable ride to work
especially for folks listening out there
who are like well I got it you know one
hour commute to work my car is
everything I pretty much live in my car
and I understand that in those
situations you want to have a
comfortable ride but Pat this is where
you need to decide what is better for
you a comfortable ride or saving that
money each month and that's really not
for Josh and I to decide that's for you
to decide but but if you're asking Josh
and i's opinion yes get rid of that car
payment and ultimately if your only
three miles away from work then then
walk to work even if it's raining like I
got a raincoat if I'm biking it's it
sucks riding in the rain don't get me
wrong but I have ways to keep myself dry
and to make it a good commute to work
Ryan you're 12 or 13 year old Toyota
Corollas probably worth a thousand two
thousand bucks by this point maybe three
thousand okay but my point is that it's
a comfortable ride and and I mean it
leaks when it rains but that's all right
right right but my point is you can buy
a thousand dollar car two thousand
dollar car that is comfortable for your
community the problem we get into is so
many people are get become tied to their
job that they buy this car to get them
to their job so they can afford to buy
the car to pay for the car that gets
them to their job that they need for the
car that gets them to their job that
they need for the car that gets them to
their job it's just a circle of debt and
eighty and stress and it's not necessary
when you realize you don't have debt
anymore and you don't have a car payment
the freedom of that means okay if I want
to upgrade to another car I can do that
I'm just going to save some money and
allocate it to that appropriately if you
have any debt though you don't want to
take on more debt you want to be able to
pay off the debt and then you can
upgrade to the car that is more
comfortable for you yeah I would say
even if you find yourself in a situation
where you're like I have to buy a car
because I have to get to work and if I
don't have a car then I'm not going to
be able to work and pay my bills which
part of that might be a car payment if
you absolutely have to take on debt
because I know there is a listener right
now who is saying oh you know not
everyone can just afford to buy a car
with cash that's absolutely correct not
everyone can afford to buy a car with
cash if you do have to go into debt for
a car then get the absolute lowest
freakin debt that you can yeah $200 300l
na to 300 other cars oh absolutely yeah
my first car was 300 bucks and it ran
great it was not the most comfortable
ride it smelled a little funny yeah and
it might not it might not have air
conditioning it might not have the you
might have a cassette player still
whatever the point being is yeah if you
don't have two or three hundred dollars
I would even recommend not taking on
debt for that personally I would say
save up for it and use public
transportation walk bike do something
else in the meantime so you can get the
two or three hundred dollars to to to
pay for the the clunker basically it's
okay to drive a clunker we've all driven
a clunker at some point in time what's
not okay is being a slave to debt yeah
it it's okay to drive a clunker at 30
years old or 40 years old or 50 years
old I think I think that's that's
something that I struggled with when I
first got I went from you know brand-new
decked out you know Toyota Avalon car to
this 2004 Toyota Corolla and I remember
actually leaving up I was on this board
that I was still helping out with when I
was in dating I was leaving a meeting
and one of the board members was walking
out to the parking lot as I was getting
into my car he was like that's your car
man I can't believe I don't like it I
don't like it and right away I
actually felt good because I was like
huh I thought that guy was a nice guy
and it turns out I want nothing to do
with him so it actually kind of helps me
figure out who who I really want to hang
out with who I don't want to really hang
out with but what I'll say is if anyone
is judging the type of car you drive
then those are the type of people you
don't want to be around it is never you
should never be ashamed of having to
drive a little bit of a clunker to avoid
getting into all that debt yeah I
totally agree and Ryan that brings up a
really interesting point you know so
Millennials the Ryan and I are just some
sort of the tail end of Gen X and so we
call ourselves Millennials I guess so I
was making accurate
we're often lumped into either either
category or both or somewhere right on
the cusp there but but younger
millennial so we're both be 35 this year
so people younger than 30 for sure are
applying much less status and prestige
to vehicles because they don't need them
as much anymore a lot of Millennials are
moving to urban hubs and so you have
Buber you have lyft you have your public
transportation obviously we're a car is
no longer a status symbol car is simply
a means to an end it get you from point
A to point A just like the bus or the
the subway or an uber it's going to get
you where you need to go and I've seen
more and more especially with people in
Silicon Valley Tim Ferriss yeah he talks
about he has like a he stole has a
clunker yeah guys probably
multi-millionaire but his car just
doesn't matter to him and to so many
people the status symbol that is the car
that is a days of old cars are no longer
a status symbol you know what a status
symbol is not having a car payment
yeah I'd much rather not have a car
payment that's my status symbol freedom
that's my status symbol our next
question is from Ryan in Tempe Arizona
22 years old and like to think I'm an
active minimized on the contrary I have
a high paying job of technology
solutions company perfect we're focused
on business development and growth
focus on interactions with new startup
companies and trying to help them find
quick technologies to make the future
business smoother and more efficient
stuff like big data analytics to cloud
computing so I love my job completely
content with working 50 hours a week and
I loved every second of it nevertheless
um I'm not like most corporate world
growers in that I live very simply I
have what I like to call a cozy studio
apartment bed a fold-up table and a
dresser I'm constantly evaluating and
re-evaluating each and every one of my
possessions functionality in life
recently I got rid of my couch I thought
hey I'm not sitting on it enough per
month
I'm also downloading just 15 shirts so I
know I know of course it's not a
competition or challenge of who has
least I'm just kind of like you know
setting the background of me so what is
your income goes in huh you might ask
and to put it simply travel I have a big
big problem compulsively buying plane
tickets and going on international trips
so yeah recently the other day I just
bought a ticket to Mexico City to go for
the Day of the Dead festival and I just
saw that James Bond movie and opening
scene had that Day of the Dead in Mexico
City and I just bought a plane ticket
like that I have a couple tickets to go
to France never gone back to Brazil in
September um moving forward that you
travel is the only expenditure that will
make you richer and I certainly love and
enjoy these trip however it is and has
put me in a world of debt um so back in
college when I was doing that when I got
my four-year degree in economics I had
two ition women bored all covered on
scholarship
and I still managed we calls about 25km
debt in student loan debt that was all
to travel let me put it that way now in
one year of working I've also added
about 10k and credit card
come from both of plane tickets and
travel expenditures you know Ryan you
really had me up until the debt part I
mean you say you have a high paying job
but how do you have a high paying job
and you're going into debt but you're
still a minimalist you mean you're not
spending this money on on stuff on
superfluous things but you're acting on
impulse oh yes let's let's talk about
this let's talk about have an
intervention making really really good
money but spending better money oh
that's a bad equation let's let's give
you an example if I make $100,000 a year
but spend $200,000 a year on travel
what's going to happen I'm going to go
into debt now now Ryan you have 25,000
in student loans and another 10,000 and
credit card debt from traveling you're
gonna have to pay that off before you
can travel anymore that's the first
thing you gotta do you've got to get rid
of any debt before you allow yourself to
travel again and then once you do that
the way to do it more deliberately is
ask yourself some questions first off
you need to stave off the impulse right
if you're making these these impulsive
decisions that's that's okay if you can
afford it but it's not as meaningful if
if you were to just plan it's not as
meaningful as if you were to just plan
it out in advance and so so quite often
when I'm going to purchase a new
material possession that costs more than
a certain amount of money I will put it
off for at least 30 days and I'll say if
I still want it in 30 days if it still
makes sense then I'll get it so the
questions that I ask will it add value
to my life but then also can I afford it
because just because something's going
to add value to my life doesn't mean
that I can afford it so I need to be
able to answer both of those questions
affirmatively
before I bring it into my life and the
same goes for traveling you can have
these great experiences and I applaud
you for doing that yes you will become a
much wealthier man in a different way
and not monetarily wealthy but
experienced rich by by going on these
experiences but only if you can afford
them and so you're going to have to find
a way first to pay down your debt I'm
going to recommend a nest
that Ryan and I wrote a very long
drawn-out process
it's called financial freedom five
difficult steps to getting out of debt
and those difficult steps are
intentional you can also go back and
listen to our our money episode or our
money podcast and we'll put both of
those in the show notes or you can just
go to the minimalists com freedom that's
that financial freedom essay that's the
exact plan we use to get out that you've
got to start there
you can't keep adding to the debt the
best way to get out of the hole is to
stop digging yeah so traveling I totally
agree with you Ryan traveling is a great
way to grow it's a great thing to spend
money on buying experiences over things
but as Josh said to reiterate if you
don't have the money stop spending it
the good news is though is that you can
still travel you don't have to be a
millionaire you don't have to you know
have a ton of money to travel I mean you
may not be able to go to Day of the Dead
impulsively or impossibly buy a ticket
to another destination across the world
but you can still find ways to travel on
a very very cheap budget to still
suffice that itch and to still have
those growth experiences because it
still is important to have those
experiences for sure you're just going
to have to approach it a little bit
differently yeah and when we'll get
we're getting some more questions here
at a moment about how to travel on more
of a budget but realize you just because
you're not staying in the W Hotel and
every single study doesn't mean you're
not able to enjoy the experience we've
had some of the most profound
experiences that Ryan and I have had
have cost us literally nothing the best
things in life are free they say and I
know it's a it's a cliche but it ends up
being true you the things you remember
or aren't the things that generally cost
the most the things you remember are the
overall experiences your interactions
with other people other cultures other
communities and that will allow you to
grow in a way that racking up the debt
on your credit card certainly will not
in fact racking up that debt is going to
prevent you from growing in many ways
because it's going to anchor you to
whatever you're doing and keep you from
being free you know we'd love to hear
what you have to say if you have any
minimalism tips or
or comments about traveling feel free to
give us a call leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine will air our favorite comments and
tips on a following episode okay let's
move on to our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round where we
answer questions from social media we're
on twitter and instagram at the
minimalists and facebook.com slash the
minimalists alright our first question
is from LBJ what's the one item that you
find the most useful when traveling for
me it is my backpack I got a mission
mission Shh mission workshop mission
workshop they're a company out of San
Francisco thanks for the help on that
mission workshop bag it is a I don't
know how many liters it is it's a lot of
leaders I want to say it's probably like
a thirty five liter if it's not forty
five liters like I like the biggest bag
that they have but what I love about
this bag is that I can literally like
fold my clothes all nice and neat and
they will stay folded and wrinkle free
in there Oh Micah for my laptop in there
literally everything I have goes in
there
or I could just cram everything in there
if I really really wanted to but but
that's what's really nice about it I can
I can carry everything with me that I
need and then oh by the way it is that
perfect size for a carry-on bag alright
still fits in the overhead light yeah so
I don't have to I don't have to carry
multiple bags I'll have to check it it's
just the perfect size of to help me
bring what I need and to prevent me from
having to check a bag I got a new bag
recently because I'm finally retiring my
Malcolm font EA bag after bringing it on
the road many many times and beaten
beating it up repeatedly it has finally
seen its last days the new bag I'm going
to be trying out for this tour is called
it's by a company called manole and I
supported their Kickstarter our friend
leo told me about the bag and so I can't
really recommend it yet because I
haven't used it but we'll see you know
behind the scenes if it really works so
if you want to check it out you can just
follow us on Instagram and although
in places on social media I'm sure we'll
have some photos but for me there are a
few things that I keep on the road we
already talked about a hairdryer earlier
on that is one thing I do bring with me
I always bring chapstick with me but
that's something I just have in my
pocket all the time so I don't know if
I'd be a Travel effect and then in our
pack like the minimalist video one one
secret of mine is I always pack one red
pair of underwear now that's not a
superstitious thing it is just that when
we are out trying to wash our clothes at
some point I know exactly how many clean
pair of underwear and dirty pair of
underwear I have it's all my underwear
is black but it's separated by this red
pair of underwear take notes
the secrets underwear yes the secret to
minimalist travel is having one red pair
of underwear no and it works really well
for me except there was one exception I
accidentally washed all my clean clothes
once and forgot to wash it dirty clothes
because I wasn't paying attention so I
wrote an essay about this a similar
story that happened after that
I accidentally bleached all of my my my
color clothes smooth yeah and and it
just taught me to be more deliberate and
even with these menial tasks like
washing dishes or washing clothes it was
the best reason for being in the moment
now I tell you back in the day my
corporate self Ryan I would have freaked
out and been so upset and then I just
realized I just sort of shrugged my
shoulders and said oh well I mean those
clothes are ruined and that's okay
they're just clothes and it sucks cuz
we're gonna have to spend some money to
replace them but lesson learned I need
to be more deliberate even with the
smallest mundane and tasks in my life
she didn't accidentally drink the bleach
that would have been much worse
yes yes no going back from that and I
don't think so so I I pack very light
when we're on tour and and the things
that I use whether it's the coffee that
we pack or my red underwear hairdryer
toiletry kit with shampoo and
conditioner and deodorant and some
lotion yeah I have stuff that I use but
I don't pack anything that I don't use
and I think that's that's what's really
important
Teesha asks which travel experiences
have given you most so far and why the
the best travel experience is for me
it's got to be Laos I was just there in
October and it was the first third-world
country I'd ever I had ever been to and
it had totally just changed my
perspective on on my life and my
surroundings like I thought that I
appreciated everything that I have now
and I can tell you that going to Laos
helps me to appreciate everything even
more it's like it's funny cuz I didn't
want to bring any just in case items to
Laos as I was leaving Mariah she she's
like hey you might want to bring some
neosporin in case you know you get cut
or something you know you won't bring
that with you and I'm like now I'm not
going to take that with me they've got
neosporin over there well when I was
over there I broke my toe and like split
it open and when I went to the doctor
they literally gave me some gauze
iodine and like some tape to tape the
gods' down with yeah there was no
neosporin there I kind of like so people
always asked like what's the one regret
like I guess I kind of regret not having
the neosporin but I was still taken care
of like the neosporin really wouldn't
have done anything that much better for
me but I got to tell you though being in
a situation where people have dirt
floors they have holes in the roofs they
have dirt roads they are literally
burning trash on the side of the streets
my broken toe was nothing every time I
felt any pain all I could think was Ryan
you are so lucky to be able and go home
after this and get some more medical
treatment if you absolutely need it you
I have access to that and it's not just
about having the amenities available to
me meaning like you know it's great that
I can go to the store and get Desertec
or it's great that I have central air or
it's great that I have you know paved
roads at home but just having access to
to certain treatments is really what I
started to appreciate so much so you
know now when I think travel now when I
think vacation now when I think oh man I
want to go out and take Mariah somewhere
and experience something new
you know I'm not thinking Australia on
the beach I'm not thinking Florida I'm
thinking third-world like that is by far
the most I have ever I have ever gotten
out of out of any experiences witnessing
a third-world country it completely
changed my perspective on the life that
I have for me I didn't really travel
much the first 31 years of my life first
30 years of my life for sure spent most
of my time in Dayton and Cincinnati Ohio
and and didn't really leave the Ohio
Kentucky Indiana tri-state area and and
so when we first went out on the road
and just started having these
experiences where we met new people and
saw new cities and I found ways even in
an attenuated period of time to just
search out one thing in a city and
especially within 2014 when we did the
hundred city tour in every city there
were basically four things that we would
look for we look for a good coffee a
good coffee shop and there was a reason
for that like not only did we want good
coffee but that tends to be a cultural
hub it's that third space for many
people between work and home and so it
becomes a community hub and you get to
meet really interesting people there you
get to have shared experiences in a
place like that and plus you can sit
down and have great conversations it it
lends itself to having really good
conversation so coffee shops we always
look for the great coffee shop we'll use
Google or Yelp or wherever to find that
and then Thai food we have tried really
great Thai food and probably 40 states
at this point and still the best Thai
restaurant in the country is in Dayton
Ohio ty9 we'll also look for sushi while
we're in town but one of the things I
really liked we started doing when we
were on the everything that remains tour
is museums anytime we're in the city we
would go to a museum and anything from
just phenomenal museums where the
architecture was great like in Des
Moines or places like that to place it a
really great local art like Boise Idaho
and memorable experiences where you get
to experience the community you get to
experience a little flavor of the
creativity of what's going on
in that city and then also because we
were on a book tour just a local indie
bookshop that's there another great
cultural hub and I love bookstores
personally but finding a great indie
bookshop when you're in town I find them
we find those four things you get a
rather well-rounded a relatively
well-rounded experience of the city if
you're just going to be there for a day
or so I'd love to hear what other people
have to say about that as well
zineb asks do you have any tips on how
to pack lightly yeah
good questions and up next question now
I'm just kidding yeah we have plenty of
tips on how to how to pack lightly first
off you only need one pair of jeans
there you could look online why do I
only need one pair of jeans why should I
never wash my jeans or as plenty of
articles out there to read on why you
need only one pair of jeans you need
only one pair of shorts to double that
can double as workout pants swim trunks
or you know going out and Josh mentioned
it earlier I got the same shorts as him
there's just a black pair of shorts I
will wear those swimming or I will wear
those out to dinner there they're nice
enough to do that so try to find some
things that that will that will be
multifunctional and then we talked about
this earlier as well just pack pack for
a week if you're gonna I'm sorry let me
rephrase that pack for a week at the
most
so if you're gonna be gone for three
weeks pack for a week if you're going to
be gone for five days and just pack for
five days you don't need to pack for a
week but but if you find yourself going
above them traveling above and beyond a
week usually you will be able to find
some type of laundry facility laundry
service to do laundry that that has
certainly helped me especially like the
jeans thing I know that sounds really
like trite and simple but that really
helped me out because jeans takes up a
lot of space in a suitcase and I used to
have three to five pair of jeans at all
times it stems from being in school were
like if you were the same thing twice in
a row you got ridiculed so I always made
sure to have like three to five pair of
jeans and alternating those out well
when you bring
three pair of jeans with you that can
very easily take up a large percentage
of room in your suitcase so the one pair
of jeans saying like that was huge for
me but there are a few tips there for
use in em I hope that helps yeah I think
that the just in case rule will
definitely help you out you can find
that at our website the minimalists comm
/ji c that'll be your your biggest tip
for sure don't pack anything just in
case danielle from california asks do
you set limits on things you can buy
when traveling yeah absolutely you know
I set limits in my life when I'm not
traveling as well and I think that's
important but when I'm traveling I I'm
especially aware of what I'm bringing in
because I have to carry it with me and
so generally while I'm traveling I
purchase very little I try not to buy
anything at all and then when I'm at
home I still have those same limits and
that question does this add value to my
life is it going to serve a purpose is
it going to bring me joy that's even
more important while I'm traveling
because I know I don't want to add to
the weight the literal weight that is on
my shoulders now Danielle you're in
California I'd love to send you we have
a bunch of screenings of our
documentaries I'd love to give you a
couple tickets to minimalism a
documentary about the important things I
hope you can make it to one of our
screens there we'll have Shawn send you
a couple tickets so you can bring a
friend there's a whole segment about
travel in the documentary as well
Mary Wright's sleeping accommodations
tent car some other way Mary yes all of
those things we we have used sans the
tent I have definitely slept in tents
Josh isn't much of a tent guy but do
tents but we have definitely slept in
our car we have slept on hardwood floors
we have slept at couches couch surfers
homes we've done Airbnb pretty much the
way Josh and I approach travel is what
can we afford so on that very first tour
that we went on in 2011 we didn't have a
whole lot of money so we slept on a lot
of hardwood floors we spent a lot of
nights in our car now that that uh we
can afford it a little bit more yeah we
will we will totally go get an Airbnb
which are kind of my favorite places to
stay I mean a hotel don't get me wrong
that's that's that's an okay like box
experience but when you when you go to
an Airbnb you just get a little bit more
of a feel for the community and you can
meet some really cool people whether
it's the homeowner or whether it's the
neighbors or whether it's reading the
guest book of past guests it's it's
really cool to stay in those places
tress rights we're traveling with two
small kids and I'd love not to overpack
but I also don't want to have to buy
something I forgot at home for me I went
Becca and her daughter Ella and I all
went to their family's house for
Christmas last year we spent something
like nine days out there and so
obviously had the pack for Ella as well
and Becca
now here's going to be a common
criticism I expect we're going to get
here yeah but you're a couple guys it's
so much easier for guys to pack
Becca embarrasses me every time because
I will pack up the car and she has a
suitcase and it's a relatively large
suitcase there only a suitcase but then
when we get to wherever we're going like
we were at the container house last
weekend she open it up there's virtually
nothing in there it's like it's mostly
empty but it's her own the suitcase she
just packs what she needs and I am
constantly amazed she inspires me to
want to pack less Medwin list yeah she's
totally showing me up and it's the same
with Ella I found is we don't have to
pack all these toys and games and things
kids are content with virtually anything
you know Ella is content when I blow up
a balloon for her she can have fun until
it pops with that balloon and I realized
that we don't have to pack all this
stuff the kids aren't going to miss it
they're going to realize they're going
to have fun with the experience not with
the stuff and so yes you're gonna have
to pack some stuff for the kids
obviously we had to pack stuff for Ella
we had to bring her diapers she was
still in diapers at the time and we had
to bring extra change of clothes because
she does get dirty but we realized that
all the superfluous stuff that we had
the desire to pack a fur so I better get
this doll I better get this blanket I
better get this and this and this no
what are the essentials so that's the
question I'm going to ask anytime I'm
packing something for Ella's what is
essential now I'm not going to ask Ella
what's essential because she's going to
have seven suitcases full of toys and
imaginary toys and she's going to pack
up the
a the the kitchen utensil she would
bring everything in the house because
she enjoys playing with that stuff in
the moment but the truth is what's going
to be essential for this trip and yes
there is a difference between just
encase items and just for win items
you're going to have to pack some
diapers because you are going to need
them those are just for when you need
the diaper you're going to bring an
extra pair of clothes because if you
have a two or three-year-old you know
they're going to sell the clothes so
you're going to need more than what you
would bring for an adult but that's okay
you don't have to pack all the
superfluous stuff in the meantime we
found that out there in Christmas
everything we brought we use we were
able to wash the stuff when when we
needed to and we didn't pack anything
that was excess and it worked out really
well
Lucy writes what if I like bringing
souvenirs back how can I find one in
line with a minimalist lifestyle Lucy
I'll tell you the only souvenirs that
I've purchased over the last or going on
six years since we started the website
are postcards that I've sent to my
girlfriend and she has compiled those
together she's making a nice little art
project out of it but but it doesn't you
don't have to get a souvenir that is you
know if you go to Paris you don't have
to bring home a little Eiffel Tower if
you go to you know Seattle you don't
have to bring home a little a little
statue of the Space Needle you could
certainly take pictures of those things
to help trigger those memories those are
actually some of my favorite souvenirs
are our pictures that I've taken with
folks when I was hiking the Appalachian
Trail I kept like wanting to go which I
only hiked the Smokies portion of it
it's not like I did the whole thing but
I kept wanting to grab rocks or sticks
or something to take back with me
ultimately I didn't do that but I took a
picture with this group of folks we ran
into and that's like my best memory of
the whole trip was running into that
group of folks so there are some very
simple things you can do when it comes
to souvenirs all right let's move on to
right here right now this is where we
really quickly get to talk about what's
going on the lives of the minimalist as
you know we have a documentary coming
out find your nearest theater at
minimalism film calm you can see the
trailer there you can follow all of our
behind the scenes antics on tour we're
at facebook.com slash the minimalist
Instagram periscope and Twitter at the
analysts and also I've got a writing
workshop coming up in June you can find
all the details for that if you want to
learn how to write better that's what
it's called how to write better it's a
one-day workshop two-hour workshop
June 26 lemma today eating how to write
better org and finally here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hey guys
brave from New Jersey I just finished
listening to podcast 17 about health and
felt like I you guys were directly
talking to me I burned 50 last year
completely changed my diet I started
eating paleo actually through the paleo
world is how I found you guys in the
first place
I've lost 27 pounds and haven't felt
this good in a long time keep up the
good work
hi guys my name is anne-marie
I'm calling from Marshall Minnesota I
listened recently to your money episode
and there was a lot of talk on that
episode about student debt so I wanted
to share a resource that's been a
conceptual piece of my experience which
is a program called the National Health
Service Corps and in this program health
service providers who agree to provide
full time service in underserved places
in the United States in exchange for
doing so get loan repayment from the
federal government so in my case in
particular I was able to pay off about
$80,000 in student loan which was
significant because I had a graduate
degree by working in an underserved area
where I have continued to live with my
husband and children and it's really
also I think living in a rural area kind
of supported my minimalism journey so
the National Health Service Corps in HSB
you can find them online and they are a
great resource for getting rid of
student loan debt hi hey this is tyranny
in central oregon and i wanted to make a
comment on podcast 18 on writing a jfm
that was an excellent podcast or should
i say that was an excellently very super
wonderfully done pod
I was trying to sneak in a bunch of
adverbs I have a tip or thought from
based on some of the tips that you gave
and thats related to blogging so I have
my attorney creates blog and my platform
is WordPress you guys use WordPress also
and I find that when I you know do a
blog post what I've been doing is just
using the you know going right to
posting and then I think what I am doing
is crafting this wonderful blog post and
I'm editing as I go along which you said
you're not supposed to do and I think
every sentence is beautiful and then I
post it and then the next day when I'm
checking out a you know a reader
comments I cope I do look at the post
again and I'm like oh my goodness what
was I thinking I've been grammatical
errors and I find slow errors and I find
some spelling errors and I'm like I
can't believe it I had done all that
effort you know the previous day while I
was writing the blog post and WordPress
you know making it so perfect so what I
started doing after listening to your
podcast is writing composing my posts in
like in a different media medium like
them Microsoft Word or you know pages or
something like that and then letting it
sit you know make at you and then going
back the next round going the next day
and editing it and when after you know
on how to day away from it just like you
had suggested and so then I think I'm
having a better product so I'm getting a
better product to post so all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalist give us a
call at four oh six two one nine seven
eight three nine and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without me
so chair your tea
Hey
you